[Music]
when we were kids during the school year
we were really
indebted to the weather people whenever
they would cancel school i remember like
watching the weather just keeping track
of it when there was a storm that may be
coming through we would often
bank on snow and we'd call it the bank
yeah so we just hit the bank open
tonight and it was the night before we
had a big test or a project due or
something or anything or cool i'd just
be not going to school but the mistakes
the stakes were always higher when there
was something
important at school the next day that we
weren't prepared for in some way yeah
then the bank would be open and if there
was any snow in the forecast for that
night never in my life have i been more
religious than on a february night
when i was before a cool age person
the night before an important day in
school the worst is when the weather
person would be like yep snow it looks
like definite snow and you're like oh
great so you totally bang on it you
don't do any of the work and then the
next day you wake up and it's a sunny
day dry is a bone that was um
i missed those times even though those
nights provided indescribable anxiety
yeah i still weirdly miss them i know
yeah oh it was just more innocent it was
when that the stakes were so high but
for something that was ultimately
pretty safe those were the wonder years
yeah well yeah anyway here's the show
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
and with me as always is am i equally
excited about missing school brother i
still think about school being cancelled
when it snows now but it's been
me too i think about decades i know that
matters well it's in us it's in our
during our formative yeah
yeah so whenever i think of the weather
or like if i see that snow icon i get
excited like like giddy it looks tingly
yes
and remember that feeling of like
going to bed and yeah like you said like
being praying literally praying praying
to god praying to god not an
exaggeration and if there is a god he
must have been so put off or she also
shows a privilege our lives were that
that was the highest stakes situation we
had i know we were lucky very um but i
remember that feeling of like you could
like there was a storm in there there
was that electricity in the air and it
was gray and dark and cold and kind of
blustery ah it's the best and you just
knew it was coming you know what i used
to do i used to be so nervous that it
wouldn't come through because sometimes
they'd be like oh almost guaranteed
guaranteed yeah big storm tonight so
then i would really bank on it and not
do any of my work and and be completely
unprepared but then i would get like
nine o'clock 10 o'clock would come 11
o'clock and it went ahead and started i
would start to panic and i remember the
feeling of staring out our bathroom
window looking at that street light
because that's you always first saw this
i had that street light in my in my room
i had one street light and it was so
great to just see when you'd look out
you'd look out and nothing was happening
and then you'd pass by the window and
there'd just be like a flood it just but
even just a few little
flurries the street light is where you
looked because that's where you could
see it illuminated ah i missed that i
remember coming into your room because
you were right next to me whenever i'd
see us like with the first sign of a
snowflake and i come running and i'm
like yes it's happening very exciting
yeah but then the world but then there
were times where it would be like
it like an amazing amount of snow
and then you wake up the next morning it
was like slush
we grew up in the part of part of the
country where it had to be a significant
accumulation to cancel school it was
your eyebrows i know accumulation was
tough for me that word
uh but whereas like i talked to friends
who grew up in austin or certainly la
and it was like if there's if it like
rains in la they cancel school yeah
um but often during these years our
source for
predicting the weather
was
our guest today al roker
al roker was the source of
so much authority when it came to the
weather and when it came to school's
opening he was the source of a lot of uh
that's the thing about the weather
people back then we put we banked on
them so much we put so much
stock in what their they had to say that
if they ended up if school ended up
getting canceled they were saviors and
if
we had to go or they were wrong it would
be the worst
but yeah
he was america's weatherman yes
weatherman weatherman and then al became
he started working at today's show he
became a morning personality uh that
when we were a little bit older when we
were kids he was strictly the weather
and uh then he became you know the love
this very lovable presence in our
lives i feel like al is just ubiquitous
and he is then when i started acting and
stuff and doing promotional stuff on the
today show he became my favorite person
to uh
to to play with to pal around with
on that show and he was always is that
weird that i said that no
i pictured you two in a sandbox
he seems
like you could play with him doesn't he
he's like got that kind of nerdy he's
very fun youthful energy yeah he has a
fun energy he does i could see him
now i'm picturing us at sandbox where he
is like a propeller beanie and like
shorts and like those short overall
shorts
like
yeah al is such a character he's uh and
such a sweet person
i always loved seeing him on the today
show and a few times they let me guest
host the today show so i would do it
with al i didn't love it yeah yeah i did
it a couple times i loved it it was
great to catch up with them and so let's
get into it my chat with the ubiquitous
funny very kind al roker
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
where are you
i'm in my backyard
upstate new york got some lamb ribs
going in the
oh wow that's a heavy-duty cooker
situation and you have a is that a
smoker i've got a big green egg over
here
oh wow got this hasty bacon i got a
kamado joe
it's uh we i i like to have several
going at once
on a good day oh my god why are you
gonna have a lot of people over
no right
you know
what are you gonna do your kids are like
mutton for breakfast again that's it
that's good button uh what is oh
seinfeld belt what was that like to get
to do that you're in a classic episode
uh one of the most i know i you know
what i i was very pleased
with that there was some
book that did all the seinfeld episodes
and that one was like like
an a-minus they said it was like one of
one of the best oh that's the subway one
uh that's right yeah and uh it's called
the cigar store india yes which is very
fitting for today you know what's
happening right now yes how i mean
obviously you can't make that now the um
and how do you how do you feel about i
mean
you just mentioned you're in a it is a
classic uh but it's problematic they're
problematic uh aspects of it
how do you feel about that like an
episode like that specifically
well you know i think an episode like
that is actually pretty instructional
about today because
it it talks about
i i don't i think you know jerry
seinfeld of the this you know seinfeld
sitcom would have thought himself
probably a liberal and and
certainly
a person who's very tolerant and yet
it shows
how ingrained
uh in a sense institutional racism is
you know whether you're talking about
native americans or you're talking yeah
it's just it's there
and and the episode points that out
in a comedic way
but
you know it does yeah it's something
that we've all and that's that's a
perfect example of something uh an
aspect of institutional racism that i
just grew up with i grew up accepting
that something like you know an indian
in a cigar store or or any sort even the
word indian
um i was not sensitive to a lot of the
nuances of of uh
the realities
yeah
redskins cleveland
you know oh my god yeah you know nobody
nobody would have ever put up with say a
baseball team called the uh the the
newark negros or the jersey jews they
just would i know i know and yet and yet
you know we have this so
you know i i think we are at a time
right now
and i think you have to be careful uh
because i think you know we've talked
about
people
are almost
up until now been afraid to have the
conversation and i think
if you are people of good will if your
heart's in the right place you can't ask
a stupid question you can't ask a bad
question
uh but i think we've been afraid yeah
i'll ask a stupid question do you know
when the new jersey jews season begins
i think it's after shabbat yeah it's got
to be out of respect that struck me when
i was listening to your book which is so
good and there's so many of the things
that i wanted to talk to you about today
uh were answered so i'll just encourage
people to to read it to listen to it
because you have such a great voice
obviously so i i've been enjoying
listening to it but um you came up
professionally during a time and you
touch on this really beautifully in the
book when somebody who looks like you
many aspects of your aesthetic it was
not typical of somebody like you to be
in a business like uh the news to be an
anchor person oh absolutely yeah i
started in 1974
and so there were not a lot of uh
certainly in upstate new york where i
was going to school and got my first
television job in new york city you had
a number of people of color of blacks of
asians of hispanics but upstate new york
was still fairly white yeah and i i was
going to be the first
african-american to sit on the desk five
days a week
you know the station and look i give
them credit for hiring me you know thank
goodness you know they gave me a shot
but they were worried that people were
going to call in they put an extra
switchboard operator on back then we had
switchboard operating they had a
security guy and they didn't get one
phone call oh wow
i i think they were expecting the
populace of central new york to rise up
with torches to pitchforks and storm the
station you know what what do you
attribute that to al i mean do you think
it's your own your own inherent
likeability
that's what i would guess i tend to give
people
credit i have found this in general that
i think the people in charge whether
they're politicians management whatever
i think they tend to
underestimate the audience the populace
and maybe even
project their own issues on the people
that they serve or take care of so
by and large people accept people now
look they're obviously as we have seen
yeah great differences but i think when
it becomes a one-on-one you know i can't
the number of times people have said and
this was
years ago you're not like other black
people what are you what are you talking
about how many black people do you know
well
there's a guy i know at work
but do you really know it he's taller
than you
yes you know and probably better looking
but
so uh
it's just one of those those those crazy
things uh help me as a as a white person
understand what that feels like when
somebody says
and uh i've been hearing the term
microaggressions a lot and and um
occasionally i'll see one that oh i'm
sure i've done a version of that i'm
sure i've said
or assumed something about somebody uh
based on their skin color i i just i'm
sure i have uh i'm sure i've been
complicit at that how does that feel
when you receive information like that
so especially when you're starting out
in this very white dominated business
sometimes you deflect you know listen i
think it's when especially when you're
starting out you're trying not to quote
rock the boat i can't compare it because
i'm not a woman but i think it's
probably for a lot of women the same
kind of thing you know where you know
they've had to deal with these
aggressions and biases
and you kind of suck it up and you move
forward
but it's still a little bit of you
hurts inside a little bit of you dies
inside i had a an anchorman who was you
know quote mugged by an uh an older
homeless black guy that everybody knew
and he was fairly harmless and he wasn't
really mugged this guy came up and
swatted him on the back of the head with
a rolled up newspaper uh which is pretty
much the same thing
most of us who worked with the one to do
yeah if that's mugging then my
grandmother's mugged me sure please who
hasn't had that and anyway the next day
he was married to his co-anchor and they
were about to introduce me uh live
and she's about to start
mona uh before you go any further and i
don't know if you know this but last
night one of your people attacked me oh
my god
and and time kind of stands still he's
like do i go after him do i ignore so i
kind of just looked at him and said doug
why would a weatherman attack you and
then just kept going
but the switchboard blew up
uh people were living
in your defense and yeah yeah and he was
uh suspended and then eventually fired
but you know it's those things that you
think oh well he did that on error
yeah that's a brilliant deflection um
and you seem like you've probably
employed humor a lot to
dodge or navigate moments like that to
me growing up yeah you do but then there
like for example i've got uh three
children my daughter oldest is 33 my
daughter's 33 i've got another daughter
who's almost 22 and my son's going to be
18.
and every one of them has had to come
home has come home to me and asked
why would somebody call them the n-word
and and this has all happened when they
were very young when they were you know
five six years old and so you know
that's something they had to hear at
home it wasn't like they're watching
that on tv right so you know and you
have to have uncomfortable conversations
with parents yeah al what is that
conversation sound like how do you
navigate that conversation as a parent
as a parent you know you tell them that
you know people use words to hurt and
it's a word that's been around for a
long long time but that is not who you
are
uh it's what somebody tries to put on
you but it's not who you are yeah
um there's a beautiful video circulating
uh
viral video where these two little
toddlers run up to each other one white
one black oh it just made me so
happy and and there's something so
profound in the simplicity of that
embrace which is that we're not we're
born
uh loving and trusting and open bias is
a learned behavior yeah it's one of
those things where
i generally believe
i want to believe that people are
inherently good
and that as they are raised and in a
certain environment whether it's their
family or whether they worship or thing
then that's where those things
those things come in i think people mean
mean to be good
until
they're taught not to right so i just
wish there was some way to there was
some sort of reset button some
psychological reset where the people who
learned this disgusting way to look at
the world and look at people could just
kind of
you know reset because
a slight comfort has been well hopefully
these racists the people who have it
ingrained in them will just die they'll
die they'll die out and that way of
thinking will eventually just dissipate
but you know i i i feel
you know and i think when you look at
what's going on
with protest the protests
i'm old enough to remember the protest
of the 60s and 70s
and what's different now
is that it is a younger
far more diverse group of protesters
who are standing up and saying no more
something was triggered in them
and i think that this generation is far
more tolerant far more diverse far more
accepting
of people and who they are and what
and not so much what they look like but
what they are inside so that you know
that hopefully this older generation of
racists
in fact as you said yeah well there was
also something grimly accessible and
morbidly accessible about that video
that everybody saw um that's how i
interpreted it i i his cries were human
there was something very human about it
uh in in the most
you know in the saddest way the most
tragic yeah well i think here that that
people
and by people white people uh saw for
the first time i mean we've seen you
know different videos i'm sure either
kind of green or they're at a distance
or
this was broad daylight
crowd around it and the wanton disregard
for human life
and for eight minutes and 46 seconds you
know a policeman was kneeling
on somebody on a black man's neck and i
think people for the first time were
like oh my god it's a gut-wrenching
video and i don't know anybody who sees
it who isn't revolt i i know on just the
most primal
level the most human level it's uh
revolting um i can't help but think
you've done
it's just a world of good in terms of
normalizing african americans in tv on
on the news on something as simple as as
the news have you heard
versions of that from people and um how
does that feel you know it it's
interesting justin i
i grew up in new york city in queens and
saw
there were a number of african-americans
on tv uh a guy named bob teague and bill
mccrary melba toliver you saw these
folks and it is important it stresses
why it's important for people to see
people who look like them and i didn't
have a desire to be on tv at that point
but i remember thinking wow there's
somebody who looks like me
you know television almost presupposes a
certain intimacy that you know this
person yes and so i think when people
see other people
they feel they know them and now by
extension they know somebody different
from them
and in some case in other cases the same
as them and that that bonds them and and
so
you know i've been doing this for more
than 40 years that's why you know i
wrote you know
you look so much better in person you
know because it's it's it and it you
know it's funny because pre-pandemic at
least once a day i would go i i because
i always go out and shake people's hands
one person will always say oh my gosh
you look so much better
i've gotten that dude
and i know they mean it as a couple yeah
i make my living on tv yeah it's
it's inherently insulting it's like okay
so this one in in this case you happen
to think this way i always read it as
like well the few people who see me in
person may think i look slightly better
but that means all the hundreds of
thousands whatever millions of people
who don't seem you know our cringers are
hiding their children they're afraid
don't look over avert your eyes from the
gargoyle doing the weather yeah oh he's
not that hard to look at in person
my god i'm not i'm not throwing up in my
mouth it's amazing well you allude to
that um you have a very good sense of
humor about it obviously but uh it also
must it was was that an insecurity of
yours when you're starting out because
you talk about losing your hair
at a very early age i was stunned to
learn
i was losing my hair in high school wow
you know
yeah so i mean i had kind of a a larry
fine from the three stooges afro
it was ridiculous hey moe leave them
alone what are you talking about oh
anyway so i was chunky i mean i
obviously gained weight as as my career
went along but you know i i was not i
was you know somewhat self-conscious i i
i kept thinking when i got the job is
this a practical joke and somebody
pranking
what did then give you the confidence to
i mean it's such a visual medium for
somebody who had any insecurities about
how they looked and you talk about them
and
you're describing them where do you
think the confidence came from just to
even go into the audition and say oh i
could be in front of a camera you know i
had a college professor department
chairman a guy named dr lou o'donnell
he's the one who put me up for the job
right and i so respected this man and
revered him that i thought well if he
thinks i can do it ah obviously i can do
it
that was at oswego now uh at suny oswego
state university of new york at oswego
right on lake ontario beautiful two
seasons uh every year we've got uh july
4th and winter it's fantastic yeah
my family is all from rochester and and
okay yeah they had a little place on
sodas bay in on lake ontario oh my god
yeah beautiful i love a good cheese yeah
yes yes
and then you talk about ron curtis these
characters you described in such a
colorful way um
it i couldn't help but think of ron
curtis was your he was kind of like you
said uh edward r murrow of of central
news yeah he was the walter walter
cronkite
of central new york and any and and
that's it
i i write in the book the reason i call
i call them
chapters altruism that they're things
that i've learned from these people
going going forward and one of them and
even to this day i still you know ron
was was uh
was old school he was an old school
anchorman and i mean that only in the in
the best of terms in that when he was in
the office he always had a uh his shirt
on his shirt a white shirt his tie was
done his jacket was on
i while we were in the office i never
saw him with his jacket that's
incredible uh you know and it was a
professional i remember once we all went
out for hot dogs right by onondaga lake
at this place called hides and he
actually had his jacket off sitting on
the hood of his electra 225
and i was like i'm sitting here eating
hot dogs with ron curtis his jacket is
off and his tie is undone oh my god
but but to me that's like today a lot of
these anchors you know
they want to relate they've got the
jacket
but no tie
wear a tie you're on tv work you know
yes i'm on tv right now but i'm not on
yeah
it's not real tv and so nobody listens
to this show uh
al you talk about paul feig and i know
paul
similar to sam raimi he does this as
well he wears they wear it's
very proper suits it's from uh it's old
school hollywood like like hitchcock and
um yeah you know ball fake i mean
bridesmaids all these great movies but
he always is dressed in
three-piece suit pocket square walking
stick it's a look and some say oh well
maybe it's effective i love it i think
it shows
meticulous care
you take the time
to present something proper to people
well you are known for that you dress
impeccably yourself you you uh i'm
looking at you right now and even though
you say yes we're on zoom it's very
casual you still look great you you your
mat your glasses which i love your
purple glasses are matching your
button-down nice purple shirt i will say
when the quarantine began
i was
wearing
t-shirts hoodies and sweatpants and
finally my wife deborah uh who's also on
television said
you gotta stop this
it's time you got to dress like an adult
i haven't seen you with a pair of pants
and a belt
in two months it's time now let's go are
you letting your hair your beard grow
and stuff oh well i you know ironically
i had a goatee you know six seven months
even before this started oh and about
two months into it i said okay it's time
to shave because it's it's actually more
work to maintain
you know a certain length of beer yes
than it is to just shave it off that's
right you have to quaff especially the
way i see a lot of guys the younger guys
they wear these beards that seem
like they are so manicured and quaffed
you have to do it every day if i were a
woman i would think this guy is too into
himself yes he's taken a little too much
effort exactly to groom exactly if a guy
does that odds are he's probably
manscaped
right in some weird shapes like edward
scissorhand stuff that i don't want to
think about but
um
yeah
all right i was just trying to shut up
you talk about confidence yes
yeah what is that a swan
this is a good time to pivot to not that
part not the uh
manscaping part but my
below the equator um
it's my my brother's girlfriend speaking
of uh maggie she is she really wants me
to ask you very specifically where you
get your glasses and i'd like to know
too i get my glasses from a guy in los
angeles it's called dom vetro
the proprietor is a gentleman named
ashley bezema
and uh a friend of mine uh introduced me
to it okay and he he's a guy who was in
finance and you know got tired of it and
moved on to uh
he was living in italy
and met these old world eyeglass mates
and just like was fascinated by and and
followed them
and apprenticed with them and then
decided to move back to los angeles
and create an eyeglass company and he
brought a couple of these old world
artisans with them bought their machines
and so a lot of this is all done by hand
there's a bit of a weight for them
they're pretty reasonable they're not
like you know thousands of dollars you
know their eyeglass frames are like 225
150. oh my god maybe 300.
and that's i i had no idea when i asked
you that it was going to be actually a
really interesting story i thought it
was gonna be like well i get them from
the sky over on 43rd street yeah it was
it was 50 50 that was going to be
interesting yes wow
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
you know i can't help but think alba
you're talking about ron curtis and
these old school guys and you say old
school anchorman in the best way but i i
i need to get your thoughts on the movie
anchorman because when i was listening
to your book that's awesome so all i
could think about was ron burgundy yeah
you know it is and it's funny justin i
grew up i came up in that area i was
working in that era like i talked about
in the book i i
wore
nothing but polyester
my first job
you know i mean look i was a college
student all i'm wearing is overalls and
flannel shirts
and so i went to jcpenney and they had
uh this deal
for 29.95
it was a four-piece suit
it was a jacket a reversible vest
and two pairs of pants
it said there were 80 combinations so by
buying two suits one was uh was like
this baby crap green
and the other was a faux denim right
there was not a natural fiber within 10
miles
but by spending 60 bucks
i had 160 combinations the wide time
paisley shirt
but that was the era yeah i had mutton
chops wow wow it was full on 70s oh
amazing al you need as a loyal follower
of your instagram you you need to do a a
tbt
if you can find out i will you know i
i'll i will do that that's a good that's
a very good yeah
and this was before the the age of
of uh uh really for us teleprompters in
upstate new york you know so you're
reading script and you had to shoot your
own story so on film
and then and then come back and edit
your own film so you learned a lot on a
real-to-real editor yes you know you're
you're spooling it off cutting it
it was really intense oh wow so al
that's where you got noticed that
somebody saw that uh local station and
said oh this guy's got something back in
the day
a competitor if they couldn't beat you
they would try to get rid of you so oh
my god
well not rub you out okay like that not
like rub you out
but more like
okay we can't beat them their show is
number one what we can do is break them
up so a competitor news director was
send my tape to a friend of his who
worked in washington dc and said this
kid is really good oh you'll be doing me
a favor to get him out of here oh my god
and so i got hired at wttg in washington
dc
because the new a competitor
gave my tape to somebody in washington
and it was the greatest thing that ever
happened because that's where i met
willard scott oh yeah became my my
second dad and my mentor oh wow yeah
willard was at wrc the nbc station in
washington number one station we were at
i was at channel 5 the fox station well
then it was metro media and nobody
watched this it was like
old people
and the infirm
you know the only person who
we would accidentally get younger
viewers if they went to visit grandma or
grandpa in the home
yeah
but that's where i met willard and he he
took me under his wing
to this day i loved him yeah oh i
remember him well and very fondly of
course yeah he was an institution you
know and i just talked to him a couple
of weeks ago
and he's still sharp his attack he's you
know and of course he's the one who
you know a lot of people don't know he's
the guy who invented ronald mcdonald i
didn't know that what do you mean well
he did a local kid show he was bozo the
clown in washington dc i didn't every
city had their their own bozo if you
will they were licensed
and anyway mcdonald's the local
mcdonald's there wanted a character and
so he
rejiggered the costume and created
ronald mcdonald wow i did not know that
that's really cool i knew him only
actually they proceeded to get screwed
because they didn't pay him for it oh i
was gonna say isn't that sad that's the
first thing i think how much money did
he make
wow that's a you know i he must be well
into his 80s
now he's 86 years old and uh he's the
same age my dad would have been if he
was still alive and they
and there's there's uh and you know it's
it's
there are very few people and here okay
perfect example
this is a man
a pro a son of the south from virginia
from arlington alexandria virginia
and
and yet
uh his
inclination his instinct
in the 1970s was to take
a young black man under his wing
and mentor him
and eventually
years later step aside
from the today show from his network job
so that i could ascend
and and you know
that's to me though there are more
people like that out there than there
are
showing up at state capitals with uh
automatic rifles and threatening people
yeah whether or not there are more of
them we definitely need to highlight
those stories and i didn't know that al
that's really that's incredible and it
you then wonder where does that
mentality where does his mentality come
from how did he change you know uh
growing up in that environment well i
don't know that he changed i think but i
think he was always that way i assume
learn that from his parents good parents
good parenting and your own parents when
you mention having that um having to
have that difficult talk with your kids
when they come home and they've heard
the n-word
i imagine it was exponentially
more so for you when you were a kid
growing up in that time what was
interesting i lived in what started out
as a fairly integrated neighborhood and
then you know white flight happened
uh but my dad was a bus driver when i
was a kid and one of the things he would
say to me is that look son
you are going to have to work twice as
hard and be twice as good as the white
kid next to you to get half as far not
fair but that's the way it is
when you grow up knowing that you know
you want to protect your children but
you know that you can't from those
slings and allergies but you have to
prepare them yeah like my dad prepared
me
and what did when you were a kid you
remember questioning like well why is
that that's [ __ ] up that's unfair
you learn that's the way it is you know
it's like that old bruce hornsby song
that's just the way it is yeah uh some
things will never change
i do believe they are changing you keep
thinking you know as each of these
murders were happening it's like my god
this is 2019 now it's 20 20. it's still
happening how is this possible
finally this has happened and
it it's like a a a damn blue yeah
do you feel al a different sense of
responsibility or or a different uh
an increased desire to speak about these
things uh you you talk about early on
not wanting to rock the boat and going
through all these different phases of of
injustice throughout the last several
decades
have you felt something turn on in you
yeah we've been yeah we've been talking
a lot about it on the today show in the
third hour you know growing up black
raising i you know a black son
my son you know has special needs but he
also he's very outgoing he went to high
school on the subway every day i
literally would not breathe a sigh of
relief until he walked in the door each
day and i knew okay he's home he's safe
because as i've told him i said bud
listen you can't do stupid stuff you
know like if some of your buddies decide
to jump a turnstile
you can't do that because if there's a
transit policeman there you're the one
that's going to get stopped and that's
another example al i keep this is this
is how
my upbringing was so different this is
why it's so
difficult for me to wrap my head around
that moment where i would be tempted to
say well why what makes me different did
he have that moment as i asked if you
did yeah
yeah and i said look son you know
unfortunately
a lot of police are going to target you
because you're black yeah it's not fair
it's not right and that's why if you're
stopped by the police it's yes sir no
sir which i would expect you to do
anyway
but you can't get belligerent you can't
ask why you answer the questions
and if there's any kind of an issue you
call mom and dad
you know
my middle girl went to private school
in manhattan through middle school
and there was something in her and i'm
so proud of her and that
she said you know what dad i i just
don't want to keep going here i want to
go someplace where i see more normal
people where i see folks who look like
me
uh and the final straw she was a theater
major
they had done a number of plays that
were a little more ethnic but not her
ethnicity and the final straw was the
play was going to be fiddler on the roof
and she said where's
where am i fitting it yeah yeah
and so she ended up going to laguardia
performing arts oh great school
yeah and had a terrific four years of
meeting people of ethnic of geographic
of economic of religious all different
backgrounds you have parts in all four
sharknado movies do you enjoy stuff like
that doing doing oh why not yeah you
know
yeah it's like
you know it's part of the the zeitgeist
it's one of those kind of cool things
you know when you get to do a a cameo
it's like i'm i'm a kid from queens and
i'm in the credits of zombieland too oh
yes that's right you're
what
yeah how fast was i named kind of movie
drop yeah i saw zombieland too it's
great yeah uh
yeah that's right and you must have been
a kid who loved movies growing up you've
referenced the stooges oh my gosh i mean
movies animated cartoons uh television
in general i mean i just love it i loved
it that's right you wanted to be this
another thing we have in common you
wanted to be a cartoonist uh that's
right and
i got to show you some of my stuff but
what what what was your style like do
you still draw
i don't really as much as i'd like to i
still do i do a sun in a cloud kind of
as part of my uh my signature right um
you know and it's funny i was more of a
dc guy you know as opposed to marvel now
it's kind of you know they kind of
intersected it was this is what what a
nerd i was it was a huge deal back and
it was 1974-75
when spider-man battled superman oh uh
in this in this giant
format comic
and it was like oh who would win well
how could spider-man because
let's face it you know superman could
kill him well lex luthor hits him with
this this uh this red kryptonite ray gun
and now he's got super powers you know
yeah it's only when superman superman
needs to have some sort of uh setback
some obstacle in order for anyone that's
that damn kryptonite if it weren't for
that if it weren't for that it probably
wouldn't be interesting
he could take over the world yes yeah
good thing he's so benevolent um
what uh do you ever think about
you've been doing this so long you
mentioned over 40 years do you ever
think about retiring are you still
enjoying it as much as you always have i
love it yeah
it's funny my my kids have asked that oh
what are you retiring to spend more time
with you probably i'm not no they don't
they just want me out of that no uh no i
i you know i love doing this and you
know it's funny you mentioned i was just
talking to my son
the other day about how
when i was growing up 65 was a mandatory
retirement oh wow you had to retire at
65. walter cronkite one of the greatest
uh newscasters ever
had to retire at 65
wow really you know it was like and he
was at the top of his game
and yet
he had to leave
and wow you know i feel like i'm just
kind of hitting my stride yeah so
i i've not known
somebody else may have other ideas there
was no by the way that wasn't suggestive
at all i i hope i hope to god you don't
um it'll be and you know
recently people were talking about alex
trebek maybe
retiring he had health problems
obviously and um that would have just
broken my heart if alex trebek and
similar to you if if uh any al who i've
known for my whole life and loved um
here you go yeah weird al yankovic
that's right he can't retire um
uh okay well uh i know we have just a
little bit of time left this is i just
love talking to you uh and again
encourage people to read the book
because there are so many things i want
to bring up and uh you just read it for
yourself it's it's so good um you know
what
i mean i know
doing an audio version of your play yeah
what was that like
it's it's an interesting
you know because
you d do you read it straight do you do
voices which i've done i mean i've
written a couple of murder mysteries
where you know i had to do all these
different voices a couple of dialects i
mean you're kind of doing almost like a
radio drama uh whereas this is kind of a
piece of cake because you're just
doing yourself yeah well some actors
find that to be harder
i guess
although i don't know how that would be
hard well
you don't get to hide behind anybody you
have to access a more truthful
you know you have to access your truth
uh that can be scary for some actors not
me well you're not you know that nice
ladies
you are great at voices al and there are
a couple in the book when you read it
you
you do some i'm trying i can't think of
course now uh which ones but
you you're very good at that you're very
good at cartoon voices and uh i always
that's what
if i like the the the old school guys
like mel blanc
and dawes butler and and all those guys
who did chuck jones yeah
all the [ __ ] yeah we did all these great
voices
uh you know it to me that was such a
skill you know to be able to slip in and
and there are a number of actors who you
know have also done you know a lot of
cartoon voices uh i mean it's a it's a
and or video game uh voice work
it it it's a skill
and it can be fairly loose yeah
you're good i i
love it um and i love going back and
looking at some of those old cartoons
gummy bears is on disney plus i recent
not a plug not an ad uh but i recently
went back and it was it was part of my
childhood so i looked back and i i was
like oh this voice sounds familiar i
looked him up and he was the guy that
did garfield another cartoon i left i
just like connecting those dots um
oh wow yeah yeah it's
i'm trying to remember lorenzo lorenzo
music yeah oh my god
who did yes
how the hell did you know that well
because
he also uh uh was the voice of carlton
the doorman
in the in the sitcom
and you never saw him you only saw his
hand or his arm oh it was kind of like
he had a voice like kind of a stoner
stoner yeah
uh wow al well done um okay these are
quick uh but also by the way
briefly had a syndicated talk show in
the 1970s no kidding
yeah
so you you would just consume
pop culture you were a connoisseur
yeah what are you it what a shock that i
wasn't really athletic
well you were in the audio visual club
you this is a great part of the book too
where you you talk about i was like oh
just when you think i just when i
thought al couldn't get nerdier he
describes how they had a gang sign
for their club
that's right you put your finger you you
put a v a downward v and your other hand
you cross sign so you made an a kind of
like anarchy symbol
yeah and then you brought the v the it
up to a v yes
we're flashing
we were the kings of nerd it's
why none of us went to school prom you
know yes
well
well you've done okay with uh with
deborah you've been where did you meet
deborah how did you guys meet i met
deborah at nbc uh uh she was she had
come she was a crop of new new
correspondence uh and i thought she was
just a really nice person and uh went
out to dinner i mean after lunch for her
birthday and then she was dating
somebody i was married and
then she goes off to cover the first
persian gulf war
uh comes back and you know and i kept
trying to you know i was at that point
separated trying to get a date with her
you know she wouldn't wouldn't
she's like i'm in a war zone now
we're good friends you know and she
asked me to look after her apartment
when she went to cover the olympics one
year
and uh
and like every single woman in new york
you know you look in the fridge
and there was like
old cheese just nothing
i opened i wanted to see how messy she
was so i opened the oven
and
there's cardboard
on the oven rack she never used it and i
realized she'd never use the other wow
i thought oh my god and then i look in
the pantry and there's like cobwebs
so you're like well i don't want to be
involved with this person the heck
so the day before she got back i stocked
her fridge stocked the pantry left
flowers on the table
um and i got a date that's a great move
that is a great that's a good lesson for
anyone who's dating somebody who uh or
attempting to date somebody who uh needs
a lot of home improvement
yes just make sure that you have
permission to go into the house well
yeah i should have yes should have led
with that
sorry that could be a problem
yes yeah life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
[Music]
it's nice to hear the birds in your uh i
can oh thank you
there and actually there are none it's
just a recording oh okay well it's
really great recording
you would never know um it's all digital
my i found another
another reason i'm becoming my dad is uh
i've i found myself lately getting
really engrossed
with uh
birds in the yard and their stories and
we have a couple nests in the yard and
i've been it's like they're my pets like
well here comes the robin again and oh
what has he brought for his young i i'm
like
i'm
just quarantine has made me i don't even
i don't know if it's made me like uh 80
or an ornithologist i don't know how to
look at it
but we have a lot of narratives even
that even that today you know the idea
there's a black guy who's bird watching
in central park
it's like you can't be any nerdier you
know a black bird watcher and yet
somebody wants to call the cops that's
right
come on that's right i saw that come on
karen yeah
yes
if if there was a term for if you did a
roker oh man i did a roker what do you
think that would be uh well you know
it's funny there is kind of because
somebody
term uh coined the phrase rokering
because i was i would did this thing it
sounds dirty i just
i know i just stared into the camera
and and they kind of pushed in on her
and they said wow he's rockering
that's great you know that's funny
you just did it once it was just like a
bit you did yeah and it became a bit it
started to become a bit that's funny but
um before we get into the lightning
round uh i i'm
always been curious about this how often
do people
and what what is the most common form
this takes when people are like hey
what's the weather gonna be like they
want you to predict the weather
well you know i do you know my
saying is you know here's what's
happening in your neck of the woods and
so people will come up hey what's
happening in your day you know what
that's great you know because they watch
yeah so you know that it beats a poke in
the eye with a sharpshooter
all right come on i want to hear your
typical response to that i'm going to be
the guy who spots you oh hey hey what's
going on in your neck of the woods huh
well pretty much same thing as your neck
of the woods because you're standing
right next to me ah great great um well
okay all right what
what is your these are the most uh
equally spontaneous uh answers
what is your most commonly used emoji
i don't use emojis okay i gotta stop
asking this question
uh you're like our third guest in a row
who does not use emojis
no well i just you know i i it's like i
i'm an adult i can't you know
oh
you know and it's like with my kids
they'll text like uh
they'll do r
u
home uh-huh
r u and then the house it's like i say
listen i have grown children
write it out
is if your life is that busy that you
can't spell out are you home yeah then
you need to get get take a sabbatical
well usually it takes longer for me to
go and find the emoji of a cat to write
out cat um
but i you know i'll use them out to
not to justify my own uh negligence but
i'll use them to to like punctuate a
sentence you know like uh to give to
give a tone to something i've just said
like uh
you know if i want to convey that i'm
saying this in
a a nice but patient way uh i don't
expect a callback it's something to to
kind of
give a yeah um
anyway so you never you've never used
them
uh i tried in the beginning and i felt i
felt okay okay
um
okay uh if you could be a professional
athlete how about this because we need
to put an emoji next to your name when
we do the the episode okay what would
you do okay if i would do i if i would
do like for example and some of them are
are uh are confusing like the poop emoji
i thought it was soft sir and you know
and then somebody told me that that's
not dessert i thought what sick mind
comes up with that well yeah because
it's a friendly looking it's got a
friendly face
i mean if i if i had gone to the
bathroom and looked back and saw another
pair of eyes staring at me
i would jump out the window anyway um i
don't know i guess the happy face emoji
okay yeah the bass yeah that's cool
if you could be a professional i will
accept that if
if you could be a professional athlete
uh judge's rules oh yeah
again this this may be another one that
that uh is a struggle uh if you could be
an athlete what sport would you play do
you enjoy sports out
uh i enjoy i enjoy going
yeah
to sports i don't i'm not i'm not
athletics
like everybody's all you know you can't
go to sporting events like for example i
love going to a mentor yankees i like
going out i like being out in the
outfield i like i like being there the
sun grass yeah i don't i generally don't
go to football games because
i make it a rule
guideline i try not to be any place
where there's more than 10 000 drunk
people
oh yes yeah going to a football game
because i love football it always seems
like a good idea until like 10 minutes
into being there
yeah and then it's like why am i here
yeah so anyway uh i i get and i don't
want to be i wouldn't be a tennis player
because i don't think i'd look good in
the outfits
uh i think same same reason for
basketball i um
i i think i'd be i i
i'd like to be a curler oh huh yeah you
know you got that stone
you're stretching out you know you're so
you're very limber
you're wearing long pants you're wearing
an outfit that you could walk out and
nobody would go hey what's that
yeah
so i i guess i'd go with professional
okay you're our first curler um if you
could have uh one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be wow
well now define snacks well like
yeah yeah um
i don't i go with the uh
i go with the cheetos cheese puff the
puffed one oh okay not the bait not the
fried one okay oh yeah the baked one yes
yeah that's
interesting
i know that you have uh
yeah you were famously went through
gastric bypass 20 years ago
you've been on so many diets you look
great now i should point out you look uh
very
um
what what are your dietary
restrictions now if you could
help people out people like my father i
hope you're listening
uh
sweets like with sweets like i know that
you've struck
you know i try to like i have
instead of see my problem wasn't so much
what i was eating or what i eat but how
much i eat okay
so uh like at night i allow myself three
squares of dark chocolate ah um um you
know like i said i've got glam ribs in
there and then but i've cut way back on
carbs okay wait wait
uh what a low carbohydrate what what's
what is the thing that you missed
besides the cheetos what's like ah man
that was um
i you know just ignite a good
a good grilled cheese scent oh yeah um
god yeah white bread wow not this whole
weed
by the way
if you want to take your grilled cheese
up a notch yeah instead of butter
mayonnaise really
yes
i see now that sounds disgusting but i
trust you
yes i would next time you make instead
of smearing butter on it
mayonnaise okay just think about it
butter is a fat mayonnaise is a fact
but there's a little bit more of a tang
and it ten it provides
a contrasting note
to the creaminess of the cheese
interesting okay and what and what
cheese do you rely on
american cheese yeah yeah okay let's
let's not get fancy that was it that was
a test and you passed pasteurized
processed cheese food yeah
yeah me too i'm with you uh this might
be difficult too what was your what is
your favorite movie of all time or or
maybe in quarantine what's one that
you're going back to and watching uh
like a comfort and this is and this is
not because i'm talking to you galaxy
quest ah
and and by the way
it is the favorite of all my children no
i've shown each one they love that movie
al way to bury the lead why are we just
getting to this now i i i don't well you
i we have talked we've talked about this
yeah of galaxy it is perhaps
for a comedy it is a near it is just
about as perfect a movie as you could
possibly want with an incredible
an amazingly diverse and interesting
cast yeah yeah that was yeah i was very
lucky that was uh
i would have done any movies but i've
never was that your first major movie it
was it was my first thing uh film on
screen um i got i i i'm sorry i had done
a pilot that didn't get picked up al and
this sister bonnie zane the the best
bonnie's sister debbie was casting that
debbie was one of the biggest
and they sent them uh my tape from the
pilot i had two scenes playing this
awkward nerdy kid and uh
that's how i got that role i i had been
on maybe one plane before i'd never been
to la i mean there were all these firsts
it was very very exciting but i i would
have done any movie at the time um
i just got very lucky i got very lucky
and then you're in one of my other
all-time favorites dodgeball oh yeah
you've been very kind about that
oh my gosh if you can dodge your wrench
you can dodge a ball ugh ripped alive
ladies
that's really good it's a good rip torn
by the way necessary is it necessary
that i drink my own urine no but it's
still it's sterile and i like the taste
you know i mean i will never forget i
remember there was a line where he said
it's like a watching a bunch of and i
can't say it it's a bad word but
mentally challenged people hump a
doorknob it's it's you know different
times but i i'll never forget i'll never
forget riptorn he was frustrated with
that line because he wanted to make a
real humping motion and
the director was this great guy ross and
thurber and and rip was you know i don't
know if you ever
had the privilege of meeting him yes
yeah
he was he was a tough character and uh
you know he'd get very upset
about a certain line and he and i
remember him saying well if you're gonna
you know because rawson wanted him to do
a certain move and rip said well that's
not how you hump
if you're if you were gonna hop a
doorknob you'd go like this and he
you know he'd do it really he was really
into it um
uh next time i see al i have so many
good riptorn stories uh what was he like
when was he on the today show was he
ever he was on the today show
i interviewed him
for uh uh
the larry sanders show
mm-hmm
and and uh he was just he was delightful
oh
wow yeah well
good
he wasn't we i didn't i didn't i wasn't
directing him
he had no beef with me yeah
yeah and i also think younger actors he
had uh difficulty with anyway i'll tell
you some other time um
again but another wonderful experience
thanks and you've also been very nice
about that in fact we did a dodgeball
thing
on we did that's right out on the plaza
on the plaza yeah for ben's uh charity
so here's a question for you yeah when
did you make the turn
from playing kind of nerdy guys
to you know
not so nervous uh that's a good you know
what it was i think al it was um i did
those mac commercials yes and uh
and
steve jobs
according to i'm trying to remember who
told me this but i think this is the
truth steve
thought that um
i looked i was cool steve thought there
was something cool about me and i i
don't think i think only
a computer nerd would have thought that
uh
but yeah like you said up until then i'd
been playing very awkward nerdy
characters which i loved and kind of
miss
uh and
because of the mac commercials i started
getting offers to play more
more of the straight man
kind of cooler uh right hipster whatever
i i don't know although you went back to
the nerd you went back to the nerd in
die hard
yeah yeah well yeah but action action
nerd and that was also the result of the
mac i don't know those mac commercials
led to a lot of
parts like that uh and they also wanted
somebody who was
i don't know yeah i i it was he's just
not that into was kind of a cooler part
and it was it all depends on what hits
and what people see and then you start
getting offers
uh that are closer to that kind of thing
um
yeah but uh okay
favorite movie uh is it really so you
would say galaxy quest for sure uh yeah
well at least certainly during the
pandemic yeah
because
i think it's almost more you have to do
genre favorite comedy drama yes
no you can't because is it fair to
compare
you know
whatever
yeah
even like cast a blanket or this shining
are you a horror guy al
i'm not a horror guy okay the last
quote horror kind of movie i went to was
uh uh alien and that thing popped out of
john hurt's chest i literally walked out
oh really
i
i i was on a date and i said you know
what i'll see you outside gotta go
did the date stay
yes
what
we didn't
go out we that was the last one yeah i
mean i yeah that's not surprising
i waited for about i waited for about 10
minutes and when she didn't guys okay
that's really fun i mean that speaks to
i don't know if that should be as
insulting as it is a compliment to alien
because it's such a
great movie
yeah
i was getting anxious i was getting
anxious until because you knew something
was coming yeah and then
okay
by the way that is such a cute sound
effect for what happened
uh
okay
that's funny uh if you had to live
somewhere else out you have a beautiful
spot there in
upstate someplace else uh it would be a
toss-up between either chicago or
portland oregon oh
love portland yeah
uh and as a food what do you think of
portland are you of a donut guy
or whatever
do you love the voodoo yeah voodoo
doughnut shout out yeah some of them are
a little too esoteric but i do like the
voodoo donut importantly they've become
quite the food
yes yes indeed ow you'll love this um
and i love shouting them out there's a
company called honey mamas look them up
honey mamas they're made with uh coconut
meat and honey sweetened with honey all
these great different flavors
totally paleo friendly uh no non-gmo
organic all that they are if you're
looking for you mentioned the dark
chocolate if you're looking for like a
nice
couple of
something i i can't recommend them
enough they're out of portland um
honey mamas honey mamas uh okay
again not an ad uh if you could have
dinner with three people dead or alive
whom you've never met how would they be
uh martin luther king jr
winston churchill
and
frederick douglass it's a great lineup
yeah i always wonder if people
impressive historical figures like that
if you were to have dinner with them i
always imagine like what if they just
what if they're like
ugh you know i don't want to talk shop
let's just talk about snack foods yeah
yeah exactly
the cheese do it like that yes yeah
frederick douglass is like interesting
uh who's your uh who's your favorite
muppet al i know you've worked with them
a bunch oh my favorite muppet uh fozzie
bear
wakka wakka yeah
i can see that
with a close second with statler and
waldorf oh yeah guys up in the balcony
oh yeah they're brilliant well here's my
close second to willard scott
um
you guys look like a million bucks
you've never seen a million bucks yes
like something i've never seen before
that's funny i recently tried to show my
buddies my buddy is a two and a half
year old and uh i was so excited you
know one of the reasons i really want
kids is to selfishly to show them all my
favorite uh get to re-watch my favorite
childhood movies so we tried to show her
um
she had never seen in the muppet movies
and
10 minutes she was intrigued of course
by all the muppets and kermit and she
was really fascinated but as soon as
like dabney coleman who i love you know
shows up she's like ah she checked out i
realized it was it was it's a much more
adult movie than i'd remembered yes yes
speaking of dabney coleman who's one of
my all-time favorite yeah me too uh did
you ever see the show buffalo bill no
the stream it was on nbc
it was in the 80s
and it was so the cast was uh gina davis
dabney coleman oh my god uh both from
bill maher
uh john c fiedler uh
it was this amazing show about
uh a talk show host in buffalo new york
oh wow and he was acerbic he was racist
he was misogynistic it was i'm listening
you've got to see this show and it it
it's i think it's on some streaming
service oh i'm going to leave it was
it was from uh uh jay tarsus and uh
and tom patrick oh wow it's you know
that same kind of mary tyler moore but
with a real bike oh wow it sounds like
with an all in the family oh it was
horrific wow oh i gotta see that yeah i
love that when you said buffalo bill i'm
you know we put the lotion in the basket
i was
imagining uh
that'd be a strange sitcom
yes it would uh
uh oh i'm gonna check it out uh if you
could have one super power out what
would it be fly yeah
the people who say invisibility always
creep i know there's i've always there's
always something about them that's like
real what why really yes really
really yeah
interesting and i guess a close second
would be if you could manipulate time ah
that would be great what what's the
first thing you would do with that power
the manipulating time power i could go
back and meet jesus
sorry that's really funny how casually
you said that yeah yeah i'll go back and
meet jesus
you know yeah of course you wouldn't
want to be disappointed that would suck
uh well but i think it'd be or i think
it'd be good
god forbid he's rude you know he's like
i'm with my kids i don't know they don't
have to worry about that oh hey i'm with
my 12 friends move on yes yes yeah
you're not one of us
um that's right
come back later yeah uh if you could be
reincarnated as a non-human animal what
would you pick
i guess uh a bear a bear yes yeah i'm
not going to touch it i end up in jelly
stone park oh you have a hat
a collar and a tie that's my favorite uh
it's my favorite animated in the bag
take it
now bears remember that character yeah
yogi bear baby well well no it was um
you know there was one i was a disney
one uh the ranger of brownstone yeah a
jelly stone oh it was jelly stone it was
jelly okay jelly stone park and it was
uh
yogi the ranger isn't gonna like this no
no
no i love that i bet but there's one you
gotta check it out i think it might be
on disney plus it's it's uh it's the
ranger ranger brownstone he has oh it
was done
you know that voice actor oh god i
forget his name great voice actor
it kind of sounds a little like droopy
it's a little droopy he may have done
droopy too yes he's okay now bears he
talked like that yeah um check it out
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny unattractive ah
uh yeah
because i i've been called on the track
i'm i'm you i'm used to it
uh
uh
which uh which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia sophia oh yeah i don't i don't
want to wear those pantsuits all the
time right well you wouldn't have to you
know you could wear what you're wearing
but just embody your spirit ah okay got
it um uh dogs are cats ow dogs yeah you
have any i have a do we have a dog
pepper
a little rescue oh nice um and this is
controversial the beatles are the
rolling stones uh stones oh okay
interest have you seen them in concert
i have just before uh mick had his heart
attack i
remember thinking how are these guys
doing
he's gonna have a heart attack
that's right this guy's gonna give
himself a heart attack i mean it's just
it it
boggles the mind that these guys are in
their 70s and
doing these long shots i know
it's incredible or even springsteen you
know you see springs oh my god
you know and it's funny all of these
older acts like we saw earth wind and
fire last summer a couple of the guys
are still original and they i mean they
do these incredi amazing shows they're
just showman yeah i know it's incred i
saw springsteen now going on i think 10
years ago at bonnaroo and i
couldn't i was getting tired watching
him he played for over three hours he
was
so
passionate the show he put on was just
yeah mind boggling um
and how
how do you want
what people think of you uh how do you
want to be remembered how would you like
people to think of you
uh after
i mean i hope it doesn't happen anytime
soon
about an hour
i can feel it coming
wouldn't it be great if i did die
he said he said in about an hour oh my
god we'd have to cut it out
it'll be the most played podcast ever oh
god no we'd we'd lose it we cut it out
uh anyway
uh i you know that that um he treated
people well
he was a good dad
and a good friend yeah yeah um well i i
can attest to the first part
of that uh every time i've been on your
show you've just been so kind and and
like i've said to you in the past
it's it's kind to everyone not you don't
give people status uh because they were
in galaxy quest
um uh i've seen it i've i've witnessed
it and i've always just been so uh
i've so admired that um how everyone
should be well thank you yeah i thank
you thank you
that doesn't always work but you give it
a shot well yeah you you uh you've given
it more than a shot and uh i i can't
thank you enough for doing this i know
we've gone over our time but um
i've always wanted to chat with you
it's always good to see you my friend
likewise al thank you and enjoy the ribs
enjoy the birds and uh yeah i gotta
check on them okay all right well thank
you i i can't thank you
i'll see you soon hopefully okay dude
that happened i can't do it now i'm
trying to think how he sounds he's got a
beautiful voice he does doesn't he it's
um it's like husky yes yes that's right
yeah it's a little bit it's not that
you're just like batman it's a little
[ __ ] husky but smooth i would say yeah
yeah well i it's he said you have you
have a naturally deeper
register to your voice right than he
does so it's hard for you to do an
impression about you know on his
instagram uh yesterday he had some
woodchucks
that got caught in his little sewage
thing
really yeah
this is only interesting to christian
because we've been dealing with
woodchucks where we live
i don't know why i don't know why you're
assuming it's interesting to me
[Laughter]
fair point um
yeah al's got a great voice and and
listening to his book on tape which we
did uh on a recent drive
it's he sounds like because then you get
to really well i guess you've just heard
his voice for an hour
you've had plenty of experience with it
now doesn't it sound like somebody who
really idolized and grew up
or at least admiring radio personnel
yeah it's a really good storytelling
voice you know yes i got a good one and
then
yeah
at the end
it comes in like this yes and it's a
little like
sing-songy storytelling yes that's right
there's uh there's a melody to it yes
there's a really nice rhythm to his
voice still when i see him i think about
him because i've seen that episode so
many times the thing that jumps out more
than anything
episode i mean i
i just know it so well and
well that was what 20 over 25 years ago
that episode it's a long time ago and
when that episode came out we
knew clearly who he was then you know
yeah i've known him my entire life i
don't remember a time where he wasn't an
active part of my
experience in life like that's he like
you said he's ubiquitous and he's
his voice i think just as hearing his
voice for an extended period of time was
really comforting in a way because
it you know we were talking earlier
about the snow and
and relying on the weather on him is on
his forecast
honest authority but
just the nostalgia of his voice
brought me back comforting yeah it
brought me back to my childhood i've his
voice has always been
a source of comfort you know and to a
lot of americans when i talk about
really liking al that must be a
component in that right i mean like
there's no way to escape that that he's
been
a comforting like
benevolent oh it's like liking kermit
the frog right you know it's funny you
didn't talk to him about the weather at
all
really no
that's weird yeah that's weird i was
didn't no i was curious if he had a how
he developed his passion for the weather
i think
having heard his book i think it was
more about
being a personality on there on air than
it is i don't think he has yes passion
for meteorology necessarily no i think
he'd like the showmanship of also now
but i was also curious how
in 40 years of of him doing this how how
much better he's gone how much better
forecasting is well you know this is
going to sound really insulting to
you're not interested in weather no i am
i am but i'm more interested in the
what do you call the performance element
of
giving of doing the weather
well because because the weather's
weather i mean like the weather there
are
meteorologists yeah there's scientists
who study study it and then then there's
a person who delivers right the message
right right so
or is that belittling to weather men and
women
that would have been a good question
whether people weather people i remember
doing the weather with him once he let
me do it this is one of the he used to
like let me do segments and bits with
him uh and and i i remember him
saying maybe just because he's done it
for so long but he was he explained the
barometric pressure or something with so
much ease and so in such an offhanded
way that i was i remember thinking oh he
he really knows about meteorology like
he's well versed well i think part of my
uh prejudice towards
the competency of weather people
uh twofold one
a lot of local weather people who other
people's a funny term men and women
often seem
really dumbed whether you're a
weatherman or whether woman right yeah
you know what i mean especially if you
watch local news somewhere the weather
person is often really dumb
it's it's like it's often like a
good-looking
cheesy guy or cheesy woman
and they seem really dumb also and
second thing uh that's helped this
prejudice is steve carell in paper man
he probably went a long way yes yes
he talks about coming up during that era
during the early 70s and
uh his i mean a lot of the stuff
being really into the suits and the
style and
um
whether anchorman that sound a lot like
ron burgundy and we talked a little bit
about that i bet you're right remember
sam champion yeah i know i'm not this is
no offense to sam champion i i don't
think he's dumb but mom was in a
commercial with him that's right
in fact he and she yeah that's right he
was very handsome yes and very but i'm
not that's a bad example because i know
what you're talking about with some sort
of like
i've met
sam champion's a really bad example
because he was really impressed
yeah yeah i'm trying to think of that
way you don't want to say anyone but i
know what you mean if everyone knows
what you mean i can't even name them
it's just when i'm in a yeah this is
cheesy local weather forecast and
they're like vaguely pointing at the the
board you know this is just
we gotta we gotta hey you got are you
trying to be funny they always seem dumb
yeah yeah but al roker obviously does
not seem at all dumb
so i'm guessing he has more of a grasp
of the meteoroli meteorolo meteorologist
tough one your eyebrows are darting
meteorological oh that's tough elements
you know what would be fun to do tonight
is going on i think i just had a stroke
but you know what'd be fun is to watch
on youtube
uh
weather person outtakes those that would
be a funny search on youtube uh
yeah local weather
uh local weather person outtakes i
wonder if there's been any research in
that like why are just to support your
prejudice which is probably unfounded
you know not unfounded you know we
should try to do we should try to have a
weather person as a guest on the show
someday
so you could
ask them
yeah but al would say
you know al was like he's very
self-deprecating about his looks but you
don't know what al would say i bet he
well i don't know what he would say
about our
theory that there are a lot of
dumb and some weather men
but uh he did sort of allude to that did
he not in his book if not in this past
interview in the book he does when he
was coming up not that they're dumb but
um
that
it was uh well because it's it's an
on-camera
profession
so
you you know it doesn't look good yeah i
mean like especially the weather because
like now i'm thinking about the weather
person as just a vessel just the deliver
like
which we were talking about since the
beginning where we would like want to
shoot the messenger if it was if they
were like tonight actually there's no
snow i have a theory what as to why
whether people happen to be good-looking
usually local weather people
because weather is such a often
such a
negative upsetting part of the broadcast
for people they get frustrated by it
that as a way to prevent people from
turning the channel in a frost like
because they're angry about the forecast
because it's depressing that oh the
whole weekend's gonna be rained out they
want to put some eye candy on there
to keep people interested i think it's
simpler than that
if what you said is true
then al as a weatherman makes perfect
sense because he's so right
he is he is
so applicable but i think you're a
perfect word but i think your theory it
makes sense but i think
there are so many
physically attractive weather people
because it's i think it's simpler than
that i think easy to do and it's easy to
do i've done it
it's hard to hear here's what's hard
about it you're not that attractive no
no i'm not saying that saying i'm saying
just as a thing as a performance you
you know it's tough for me well that's
why the brook tamland a character is
funny exactly and uh relatable like that
it made sense that that character was
that stupid yeah here's what's
challenging i wonder whether people were
offended by that movie um i bet they
were that they were al seemed to like it
he did yeah you know what's difficult
about it the times i've done it is
keeping track of where you're pointing
so you have to look at the monitor
because you're on a green screen and
you're just point you look like a maniac
you're pointing to nothing and you're
talking about you're referencing you're
gesturing to these things that aren't
there i guess that requires some
intelligence it requires hand-eye
coordination really good hand-eye
coordination and um and a buoyancy and
uh you know there's a real performance
element obviously to it which is why al
is so good at it god willard scott was
great and sam champion these people and
a lot of
women too it's funny how into uh
clothes he is
that he
he's so dapper this sport he picked his
dream sport oh yeah he based it on the
outfit he would have to wear he said
well i can't play basketball because i
wouldn't want to wear that outfit and uh
no
and uh forget forget baseball i'd have
to wear that outfit how about curling
i bet you or dressage i bet you're doing
this our last
guest whoever picks curling didn't
somebody say curling no
i don't think so
i think so maybe i'm wrong shorties
shorties you think he's i bet you're
wrong i mean really depends on how long
the show lasts but currently i'm sure i
bet somebody might say it like
ironically but he said maybe maybe but
but let's it's another well-dressed
sport that is for gentlemen
ladies
polo yeah cricket dressage um
some sort of horse right are you
picturing al writing
yeah he's very fashion forward and he
picked
sophia as the golden girl oh yes he
didn't want to wear a pantsuit yes
i had no idea he was that into fashion
but he talks about it in his book he's
really he's really into it well he i
mean he it to him it was about having a
level of respect for your job but as a
young he talks about it as a young black
person
uh going to an a job audition like that
with all these white people
you stick out and he was overweight and
he said he's balding and
you know
yeah i don't really understand how he
worked up the balls the balls to do that
what hutzpah and he was very tenacious
yeah he talks about in his uh in his
book
really really tenacious who were you
watching that had that tonight oh uh
stefan marbury that documentary we saw
last night chris there's a great
documentary it's about stefan marbury uh
look it up on hulu or netflix it's so
well done i think they examined stefan
the marbury and his family's dr the
drive that they had let's read a letter
okay
this is from jordan
jordan hayes subject would you rather us
and whatnots galore yes
hello fellas
thank you both for being so
authentically you and entertaining me
with life is short
it [ __ ] is
also it's my favorite
okay it's a tie with armchair expert
podcast the podcast yeah not life no
no
and i save new episodes from when i'm
cooking dinner ah that's cool it's nice
to have some good old-fashioned dork
good old-fashioned what
i was like oh this is so complimentary
and flattering
good old-fashioned what dorkery to
listen to dorkery yes
thank you
oh that's thank you i'm glad you're
enjoying it
he said it's what i love
i was listening to a couple of dorks
wait is jordan a man or a woman i don't
know oh why'd you assume man yeah or it
could be
something else yeah it could be a woman
or something like that yeah yeah we
don't know i don't know
i
might just i'm curious if
i'm curious binary question it was a
very binary question i think
i i would have assumed woman i think i
think i know more female jordans but go
on
well i
he says hello fellas doesn't that sound
like something a guy would say
i think uh like a cool lady would say
that a dorky guy might say it
fellas well let's keep reading okay
maybe we'll get some more clues he likes
dorkery he uses the term dorkery see
that sounds more like a lady oh you
think we shouldn't be judging this no i
know but i'm curious now okay that's
right i say
man i
he at least identifies as a man i say
woman go on i live in sonoma county
any clues there no
smack dab in the wine country where i
was born and raised i met my husband
still
right
skateboarding
when
the plot thickens when i was 16
and fell for him hard on our first date
at the skate park
in parentheses literally i fell and hit
my head and was taken to hospital by
ambulance and stayed there for over a
week in and out of consciousness with a
fractured skull and concussion lost my
senses of taste and smell for a year
what that's a crazy parenthetical that
was a parenthetical
lost
smell and taste for a year yeah and and
we've been together ever since
that's actually we should tell maggie
that that can happen that's comforting
to know because that's it that's a great
meeting story too oh it's
but what a great story great story and
you could always say you wouldn't
believe it
i fell for him but that's what she says
yeah it's great literally i fell and hit
my head wow this october will be 25
years wow
that's cool good for you and your um
good for youtube you and your husband
people
uh and we and we haven't left the area
he's been a pretty good shelter-in-place
mate despite all of his quirks getting
magnified to an annoying degree
also i'm pretty sure my critiques on how
he fills the dishwasher suggestions on
eating without making any sound
and daily dissertations on the
importance of a regular exercise regime
or annoying the [ __ ] out of him on the
regular wow but we consider ourselves
lucky to have each other especially now
we are also really lucky to be
self-employed and be able to work from
home
i've been inspired by you guys in the
whole would you rather situation
definitely this was a favorite for me
and my siblings growing up on par with
mad libs oh yeah we like love live love
mad libs i still do i like a good man
your childhood joy bad lips don't have
to extend it into adulthood for both of
you
uh i've passed on the joy to my niece
and nephews and try one on my husband
every once in a while i feel my choices
have become more refined through the
years
i've graduated from the choices of
swimming in a pool of boogers oh my god
my stomach just turned
that is so disgusting to me
uh that's so gross a whole pool of
boogers can you imagine to accumulate
that many boogers what what it how of
doesn't bother me that much
or a pool of spiders that would suck too
but there's something nauseating okay
okay here are a few current dilemmas
from a sophisticated lady yes
damn it
okay here we go uh these are jordan
female jordans would you rather number
one would you rather
never be able to orgasm or never be able
to sneeze
to clarify you could get to the almost
but never reach the explosive bit at
each case oh my god i don't get the
argument for
picking sneezing
do you
no
that's uh
it's so easy it's so easy
i'm in fact like i'm trying to make
concussions you know i have really like
pleasurable sneezes
really pleasurable sneezes
in fact
i will say it's extremely frustrating to
get close to a sneeze and not be able to
do it yeah but think think about getting
closer to an orgasm and not be able to
do it much more frustrating yeah because
it's much more
pleasurable yeah there you go
no no contact you know is that true have
you heard that is that an old wives tale
an old horny wives tale that um
six
sneezes
are the same as an orgasm or that one
how does i don't think i've ever heard
of that i've never heard that one orgasm
i used to hear that your heart stops
when you sneeze
i've i heard that that um an orgasm is
the equivalent of six sneezes at the
same time
like in terms of abandon in terms of
like ah like letting go
is that a horny wife's tail
what you just did with your hands to
describe an orgasm was really gross but
that feeling of like i know
uh lack of control yeah yeah like if you
had it's like the good version of
vomiting it's like sneezing in a car how
scary yeah
that's
gross uh i would pick um yes yeah easy
orgasm um number two would you rather
always have to wear flip-flops or always
have to wear cowboy boots
you would have to wear them all the time
except when you shower also the flops
would be really crap thin ones doesn't
she write like an english person yes
also the flops would be really crap thin
ones and the cowboy boots are red hmm oh
okay you know i'm not sure if i've ever
worn cowboy boots um they i've heard
they're uncomfortable they're not the
most comfortable
uh
if we're gonna take climate out of it as
a factor because i like living in in the
northeast yeah so what would you do in
the winter time right so uh but let's
say that's not a factor it's just about
what you'd rather wear out and about and
you never got cold
okay
uh then i think i would pick i guess i'd
flip flip flip-flops yeah here's the
problem with flip-flops the big one
can't run it's also yeah we can't you
can't really run and play sports within
cowboys yeah that's true
yeah and the thinner ones the other
argument for the boots is if you were
always wearing flip-flops you'd
have to be more concerned with your feet
and what that i was going to what state
what state your feet were yeah you'd
have to take care of you not that my
feet are like
ever that gross or anything yeah that's
a good one i would pick flip-flops
flip-flops and orgasms so far okay
oh you'd have to wear them when you were
having orgasms unless i was in the
shower
that's true
all right would you rather be colorblind
or never be able to hear music
i've thought about this oh not
colorblind i've thought about being yeah
see i would rather be deaf than blind
but
i would rather
be colorblind
than me too not be able to hear me 100
because even if you're colorblind you
can still see beautiful things
but your sense of color is really off
but you still yeah correct me if i'm
wrong but i think even if you're
colorblind you still see
different colors you just don't know how
to identify them right
i think they're just it's not like if
you see a black and white world i think
most people who are colorblind can see
colors right but i think so it's not
like they mistake green for
you know yellow or hi that's how i think
all right but we don't know enough but
definitely colorblind okay orgasms
flip flops color music so far i have
orgas
orgasms flip-flops music and then she
says uh so those were three and then she
said sorry no poop ones but maybe next
time you know what's funny yesterday uh
our mother
shamed me but us for doing too many
scatological would you rather she did
yeah she's like yeah enough she's like i
like when you do those would you
rather's but
it's a lot of a lot of
scatological ones
didn't like that so she might like this
one show like she'll like jordan yeah
uh except for the orgasm one she won't
like she will not like that well i don't
know i shouldn't say that
i don't want to think about it no that's
not so by the way thanks for talking
about her mother after that conversation
really appreciate that
uh no poop ones but maybe next time i
hope yeah i hope there is next time
jordan uh thanks again for contributing
joy and lighthearted energy to the world
thank you jordan you are both
appreciated all the best jordan what how
nice what a great letter thank you
jordan and if you guys want to write in
and be the next jordan
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com
thank you to the
delightful he's delightful he is
delightful al roker and uh follow al on
instagram it is uh you won't be
disappointed it's really a lot of
woodchuck contest but also his family
just seems so sweet and i just really
like following him um
and uh thank you i thank kim and um
thank you all for listening and thanks
al and thank you all
okay
talk to you next week stay safe
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's co-hosted and produced by
you christian long and
megan monaco senior producers michelle
miesh lans audio engineers sergio
enriquez executive producers are
marshall louis and ornan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
everyone uh we are ding dongs because we
completely forgot to mention al's
great book
that we love listening to it's called
christian you look so much better in
person oh that's mean no i was just
saying to say the name of al's book
that's the name of this book
oh i thought you were
oh
oh okay you look better in person too
yeah
thanks
you